you should snap it oh yeah let's do it
I'm gonna tag that in the same reason no
no don't tag Dolores Park Jeff was like
two blocks from here like a keep mocha
buttercream always shouldn't long
vacation well on the case
Wow vacation from vacation what if Texas
runs into US and he's like you guys are
here I don't know we haven't talked to
him since we sabotage this birthday I
get it you're trying to ginger fry this
place but like where's the Starbucks
Coffee is like so much better than our
coffee Greek god the women are even
prettier here too but when you're people
like us the margaritas a homie there's
something so attractive about a woman
with a kid right I thought it was crazy
now it's crazy tonight though I've got
two bottles of wine in the room this is
so embarrassing
do you have a wine key have reservations
for margaritas all right I just want to
lay out for a little bit thank you sorry
sorry okay sorry apologize for the best
trip ever
it's like the best remember it's the
best vacation ever right sorry sorry I
thought we were going to a spa
we are Derek said the best spot is in
Chinatown it has a purple sign keith
emojis oh my gosh you are so cute how
are you still single you're the nicest
time I've never had fun like this before
I brought a lot of different swimsuit
options to hear like they're all too
[ __ ]
do I go cute or hot all I ever wanted
oh that's good tagging that vacation
house yeah I have to get away or how to
get it I was half to get it have to get
away that's what vacations are for
they're about like getting to know each
other in a different level do you
deserve this maybe isn't it to be
treated like a prank okay you're right
it's been crazy lately I only have one
of the case of my family ever again
think you'll ever use the other bed all
right this is stupid I'm sorry
is it vacation all I ever wanted
vacation time to get away or is it have
to get away or is it how to get away
this is stupid I'm sorry
hot